yeah
he is one of the lucky ones emerging to
the surface shaken but unharmed
surviving a blast which killed dozens of
his colleagues when it ripped through a
state-owned mind in Northern turkey on
Friday
Rescuers work through the night to pull
the injured out and even miners who are
off duty joined in the effort to save
their friends
good Solutions
I was home when the phone rang I also
heard it on the news I rushed over and
we've been in the mines since
that all my friends friends I eat and
drink with at the weekend they all had
dreams I guess this was it they all had
families some were married some were
single each one had hopes and a mission
relatives faced an anxious way to hear
who made it out the worry too much for
some to endure
they'll be seeking answers about why
their loved ones perished and while
flammable gases could have been the
culprit Turkish president erdogan vowed
this mining disaster would be the last
one
of course we will determine how the
explosion happened and whether there is
anyone responsible through
administrative and legal investigations
these investigations have already been
launched
we no longer want to see deficiencies or
unnecessary risks in our minds
but the president's commitment won't
bring back those who are gone
and as he paid his respects to the dead
he was joined by a community deeply in
shock
this tragedy etching a painful scar in
the lives of all in this small town
Sky News